j'ai me laissent cave aznar point qu'à
vivent dans la musique fait partie de la
famille chez les bobos qui ont quatre
enfants et sept petits enfants autant de
musiciens et danseurs et chanteurs ou
petit déjeuner gabriel à la benjamine
chante sa dernière composition
on dirait la [ __ ] entier
ben mon gala blier est ce que tu es fier
d'être ici très très très fier on notera
financière des notes notre passé nous
histoire notre culture damas mis
d'accord la musique a beaucoup
d'expérience c'est une grande histoire
d'amour mais ns est lourd fondé le
groupe en 1978
quelques mois après leur coup de foudre
le couple et leur musique ont survécu au
temps au mode au coup d'état ou séisme
et où venait se demande récurrente
[Musique]
vous restez en haïti alors vous l'avez
jamais répond choisir très bonne chose
les jeunes et les policiers qui nous
donne les problèmes
[Musique]
deux musiciens très connus en haïti ne
réclame pas le départ de jouvenel moïse
car changer de président n'a jamais
réglé les problèmes du pays selon un
il souhaite une vraie révolution pour
rebâtir l'état de bahia où ça veut dire
au changement radical conscience et la
politique là j'y reste
j'avais d'ailleurs ces sept nouveaux se
tire pas dans la tête
quelque chose peut-être le coeur est à
choucha c'est chaud ou aimer plus
partagés pouvoir le système entre
genevois mois seulement qu'il doit être
bien mais les auscitains
quand je dois aime bien les aussi doit
ces artistes qui ont milité contre auch
presque tous les régimes depuis 40 ans
ont parfois dû s'exiler pour fuir les
menaces le problème en haïti selon un
c'est qu'une poignée de riches et
puissants contrôle pays pour que le
pouvoir serbe vraiment le peuple il faut
le décentraliser c'est la mafia qui
dirige le pays c'est un groupe qui ont
de l'argent qu'ils jugent les
politiciens pour que les policiers du
juge le peuple la démocratie à
l'haïtienne n est pas bonne elle est
pourrie c'est pas ça parce qu'on sait
voit la démocratie dans les ep et nous
parlons souvent de la suisse du canada
de des états unis même où tout a
décentralisé
et on a eu dix comme tous ceux vie en
chantant et en dansant
une révolution était possible sans
musique au musée peu sa touche ça peut
toucher l'âme
ça touche les spéciales le corps la
guérison peut se faire à travers une
musique à travers une chose des fois on
est en plein presque de dépression bien
mais on écoute de musique là quelque
chose se passe
[Musique]
cette façon de s'exprimer
on refuse on danse on danse et on shoote
en même temps compris entre 1 sedan
c'est prier pour nous laisser briller
aussi pour nous alors si c'est ça c'est
avant tout ça doit avoir une base
spirituelle dans la spiritualité nous
rien parce que en état cet ensemble de
personnes est ce qui vous permet
d'espérer mais en le seul où les
haïtiens nous le voulons et nous le
disons depuis 40 ans il faut que ça
change
mais aujourd'hui ça marche très haut
puisque nous le voulons nous devons
diallo bien sans parler et voir comment
changer quoi changer et comment il doit
y avoir une révolution mais cette
débauche de la meuh non
le fai l'avant et c'était joli et tout
mais ils oublient qu'ils peuvent qu'être
heureux de finir comme hérité encore
donc c'est nous qui devons faire
l'effort pour changer de pays ont-ils
atteint d'ajouter belmont gagne
[Musique]
tous